Hallo, guten Tag. Zeitz, Herr Decker ist mein Name.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz, als Tätich
und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Ich werde zuerst einige allgemeine Fragen stellen,
danach werde ich Träger über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden,
oder zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen.
Mit Ihnen sprechen.
Ja, gut, ja, klar.
Hauptsache, jemand guckt nach mir.
Ja.
Okay, und wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Frank Beedke.
Frank?
Wie können Sie bitte der Nachname langsam Buchstabieren?
Ja, B-E-T-H-G-E.
Herr Bezge.
Beedke, genau, richtig.
Okay, und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 46 Jahre.
46 Jahre?
Und wann wurden Sie genauer geboren?
Am 8.03.1979.
8.03.1979 und?
70.
70. Okay, und wie groß sind Sie?
Oh, ich bin so 1.78.
70. Und wie viel wiegen Sie zuzeit?
114 Kilo.
Okay, und was führt Sie zu uns heute?
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Also, Herr Beedke.
Ich muss Ihnen mal meinen rechten Fuß zeigen.
Also, ich kann, also, das ist wie angeknipst.
Mit einmal kann ich gar nicht mehr auftreten.
Das fing heute Morgen an.
Also, ich, als ich aufstehen wollte,
wollte ich da drauf treten.
Und das war mit einmal richtig ganz schmerzhaft.
Und, also, das sind ganz stechende Schmerzen.
Ich kann überhaupt nicht auftreten.
Und, also, das ist auch irgendwie ziemlich rot der Fuß.
Das sieht so aus.
Ja, das sieht ganz ungesund aus.
Also, ich, und ich habe mich aber nicht gestoßen.
Ich habe, mir ist da keiner draufgetreten oder so.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was damit ist.
Keine Traume, keine Verletzung.
Ich habe mich nicht verletzt.
Nein, mich nicht angestoßen.
Und meine Schuhe passen mir eigentlich auch.
Aber ist es da vorne im Fuß?
Also, ich kann gar nicht da drauf treten.
Das ist super schmerzhaft.
Vorne vom Fuß.
Rechten Fuß.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, dass es ein rot geworden ist.
Ja, also, das sieht ganz rot und dick aus.
Und ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass der Fuß so warm ist.
Ich habe jetzt gar keine festen Schuhe anziehen können.
Ich habe nur so einen Schlappen an dem Fuß,
weil das wirklich so doll weh tut.
Ich kann da gar keinen Schuh drüberziehen.
Der ganzen Fuß wird geschwollen?
Eigentlich mehr vorne der Fuß so.
Und haben Sie auch Schmerzen bei der Bewegung?
Sie können nicht einfach auftreten?
Nein, ich kann überhaupt nicht auftreten.
Also, ich habe das Gefühl, es ist ein bisschen besser,
wenn ich den Fuß hoch lege und mich ganz still verhalte.
Aber es sind wahnsinnige Schmerzen, ja.
Beim Hochlegen werden die Beschwerden weniger?
Ja, dann wird es ein bisschen besser.
Dann kann ich es besser aushalten, ja.
Okay.
Und sind die Schmerzen oder sind die Beschwerden pfüßlich aufgetreten?
Ganz plötzlich, ja.
Also, wie gesagt, ich finde, was ist denn jetzt los?
Okay.
Und strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo in ihrem Körper teil aus?
Nee, die sind da unten im Fuß, sonst nirgendwo.
Aber auch nur in dem einen Fuß, ne?
Okay.
Und sehen den Fuß, die am betroffenen Bereich Blassaus Sicht,
oder sieht den Fuß Blass aus?
Nee, der Fuß sieht eher rot aus, würde ich sagen.
Rot und geschmollen.
Schmollen.
Und überwärmt, Sie haben schon gesagt...
Ja, der hat 50 Warm an, ja.
Okay.
Und können Sie bitte dich messen genau beschrieben?
Sie haben schon gesagt, es ist ein Stichhänder.
Also, Stichter richtig rein und pulsiert so ein bisschen, ja.
Pulsierende.
Und fühlen Sie sich am betroffenen Bereich,
an dem rechten Fuß am vorne Taub als Gefühl krebbeln?
Ich wäre froh, wenn es Taub wäre, weil es dann nicht weh tete,
aber es tut heftig weh.
Aber keine...
Oder haben Sie keine Beschwerden beim Fühlen am Fuß?
Also, ich spüre da sehr genau, was da nur...
Schmissen.
Es tut sehr doll weh, ja.
Und haben Sie Fieber?
Haben Sie es gemessen?
Ich habe mich nicht gemessen, aber am Kopf fühle ich mich nicht heiz.
Also, ich denke, das ist nur der Fuß, der so heiz ist.
Okay.
Und hatten Sie früher solche Beschwerden?
Nein, ich...
Das ist der zunächst einmal.
Ich habe das noch nie erlebt, deswegen bin ich erschrocken.
Deswegen komme ich ja auch her.
Und wie sind Sie zum Krankenhaus und gekommen?
Meine Frau hat mich mit dem Auto gebracht.
Und dann haben wir an der Forde gefragt, ob ich so G-Stützen haben kann
oder ein Rollstuhl.
Und dann haben die mir ein Rollstuhl gegeben,
weil ich gar nicht auftreten kann mit dem Fuß.
Also, ich habe so ein bisschen zu Hause mit der Hacke mir geholfen,
also, dass ich so hinten nur auf die Hacke aufgetreten bin,
aber auch das tat sehr weh.
Also, ja, so laufen wir gar nicht.
Wie groß die Rötung, die Schwellung?
Ja, ich würde sagen, bis zum halben Fuß.
Und haben Sie am betroffenen Bereich ein Stichstelle?
Oder ein Stinkstelle?
Eine Stich, eine Einstichstelle.
Meinen Sie, dass mich etwas gestochen hat?
Nee, nee, jetzt gibt es ja keine Tiere mehr.
Ich bin auch nicht barfuß gelaufen oder so.
Ich habe mich da auch nicht verletzt.
Ich wüsste dich nicht, nein.
Und gerade haben Sie Atemnot?
Nein, nein, nein, mein Fuß tut mir weh.
Nur auf Fuß.
Ja, ich möchte auch die anderen Organe überlegen.
Deswegen habe ich diese Frage gestellt.
Und haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzstolpern?
Nein, so was habe ich alles nicht. Nein.
Okay.
Und Sie haben gesagt, bei der Bewegung,
die Schmerzen sich verstärkt.
Und bei welcher bestimmten Bewegungen haben Sie Schmerzen?
Zum Beispiel nur beim Auftreten.
Beim Auftreten eben ganz schlimm.
Und auch wenn ich versuche, das zu kippen,
den Fuß oder mit den Zehen zu wackeln,
das versuche ich lieber gar nicht erst,
weil das einfach zu doll wieh tut.
Okay.
Ganz klar.
Und ich würde gerne nehmen allgemeine Fragen weitergehen.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Oder hat sich Ihr Appetit in Lester seit verändert?
Der ist immer gut.
Meine Kilos kommen ja nicht von ungefähr.
Ich bin ein sehr guter Esser und meine Frau kocht ausgezeichnet.
Ja, ich esse sehr gerne.
Kein Problem beim Appetit.
Und ist Ihnen Öbel oder hat er sich schon erbrochen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Und gibt es die Willigkeiten beim Stuhlgarten
oder beim Wasserlassen?
Normalerweise habe ich da keine Probleme.
Okay.
Und schlafen Sie gut oder haben Sie Probleme,
einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Angeblich schnau ich nicht beim Schlafen.
Ja, aber das ist auch das Einzige.
Aber ich kann eigentlich gut schlafen.
Okay.
Und Herr Betzlege.
Und reagieren Sie auf etwas allergisch?
Nein, ich kann alles vertragen.
Ich kann alles essen und trinken, was ich will.
Keine allergien.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Sind Sie meinen gegen Corona oder weh?
Die alle empfingen von Kindheit.
Ja, in der Kindheit ist man natürlich geimpft worden,
aber jetzt so.
Oder bekommen Sie regelmäßig jede Jahr ein Impfung?
Ja, ich gehe jetzt, als das empfohlen wurde,
bin ich mal zur Grippe Impfung gegangen.
Als die Kinder klein waren,
ist man da auch regelmäßig hingegangen.
Aber jetzt, wie gesagt, Covid, da bin ich natürlich damals auch geimpft worden,
aber jetzt schon länger nicht mehr.
Und reisen Sie oft oder waren Sie in Lester seit dem Ausland?
Nein, wir waren nur,
also im Herbst, wir gehen hier in Deutschland untergegst.
Okay.
Und ich würde gerne auch über Ihre Krankengeschichte etwas wissen.
Gibt es Ihnen wichtige oder chronische Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, also, ja, ich habe ein bisschen schlechte Blutfestwerte,
das hat mein Hausarzt mal gesagt.
Ja, er hat mir dann geraten, ich soll ein bisschen...
Halten Sie da gegen nur Diet, oder?
Bitte?
Halten Sie da gegen nur eine Diet, oder nehmen Sie ein wenig?
Ich soll sie essen, aber das schmeckt mir natürlich nicht.
Und deswegen mache ich nichts dagegen.
Ja.
Und ich hatte ein bisschen, ja, auch wohl ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck,
aber dann nehme ich auch eine Tablette,
aber kann ich Ihnen gar nicht sagen, wie die heißt.
Wie heißt die?
Nehmen Sie die Dose?
Also, ich nehme da morgens eine Tablette,
aber wie das heißt, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht.
Das liegt zu Hause bei mir auf dem Ess-Tisch, aber...
Ja, das ist kein Problem.
Ich bin mit Ihnen Hausarztkontakt nehmen.
Ja, und dann nehme ich noch etwas,
weil ich manchmal so so brennen habe.
Und das nehme ich aber nur, wenn es zu stark ist.
Ja, dann nehme ich mal so eine Tablette.
Wie heißt sie, Omelprazzolo, oder so heißen die?
Ja, richtig.
Nehmen Sie Weiber da.
Sie haben drei Grantenheit gesagt,
und seit wann leiden Sie Bluthochwerte,
Blutfetthochwerte oder Bluthochdruck?
Ja, höchste Blutfettwerte, ja.
Ja, vielleicht schon vor fünf, sechs Jahren
hat man das festgestellt, ja.
Auch Bluthochdruck seit fünf Jahren.
Ich meine, so ein Checkup hat man das mal alles festgestellt,
ja, dass es alles nicht so gut ist, aber...
Ja.
Okay, und seit wann leiden Sie
und ja so brennen...
brennen...
Wie heißt das?
Warum ausstoßen, man, Sie wieder so brennen.
Ja, das habe ich schon,
ja, habe ich eigentlich schon lange, also je nachdem,
wenn ich etwas Fettiges gegessen habe oder so,
oder auch wenn ich ein bisschen viel getrunken habe,
dann kann das schon mal sein,
dass das so ein bisschen sauer hoch kommt, ja.
Aber das ist ja nicht jeden Tag,
das nehme ich dann, ja, nehme ich die Tabletten ja auch nur,
wenn ich Probleme habe.
Danke.
Und nehmen Sie neben den bekannten
oder genannten Medikamente, noch andere Medikamente ein.
Ja, wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe oder so,
nehme ich natürlich Aspirin, ja, klar.
Okay, Aspirin, erinnern Sie sich an die Dosierung?
Ja, das sind so 500, meine ich, 500 Milligramm
und die nehme ich dann halt, wenn ich mal
heftige Schmerzen habe, also Kopfschmerzen oder so.
Also 500 Milligramm Aspirin nehmen Sie.
Okay.
Bei Medikamente, ganz gut.
Und wurden Sie schon operiert?
Ja, ja, als Kind habe ich natürlich den Blinder
irgendwann mal rausbekommen, ja.
Und hat die Operation Komplikationslos verlauft?
Ist die gelaufen?
Das war, ja, da war ich ja noch klein
und das ist ja kein großer Eingriff heutzutage.
Das machen die ja mit so einer Schlüssellochuppe.
Das war eine schnelle Geschichte,
ich meine, da war nix aufregend.
Ja, ja, Sie haben nichts, aber Sie sind gerade
26 Jahre alt und Sie wurden als Kind
in die Operation...
Damals war ich natürlich auch noch ein bisschen schlanker, ne?
Ja, deswegen habe ich dir gefragt.
Und rauchen Sie?
Nee, rauchen tu ich tatsächlich nicht.
Ich rauche nicht, nein, habe auch noch nie gerauchen.
Ja, ich habe ganz...
Wenn man mal, wenn man von den Zweiziger retten wird,
denen einem schlecht wird, so als zwölfjähriger,
wenn man davon absieht, aber nee, ich habe das rauchen nie angefangen.
Sie haben damals gut entschieden.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, das schmeckt mir allerdings schon.
Ja, ich trink schon zwei, drei Bier jeden Abend
und auch, ja, wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt, auch mal eins mehr
und dann trinken wir auch mal ein Schnaps
oder irgendwie sowas dazu zum Café oder so, ja, doch.
Okay.
Und benutzen Sie Drogen
oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nee, nee, das habe ich nie gemacht.
Und was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Schlosser, arbeite in einer großen Metallfirma.
So, sehe ich deinen Schlüssel aus?
Nein, also Schlosser bedeutet, dass man mit Metallarbeitet halt, ne?
Metallverarbeitung.
Wir machen so Gitter und einfache Geräte stellen wir her und sowas, ja.
Okay, das ist aber muskulös belastende.
Ja, es ist körperlich anfangen,
ich muss natürlich auch Sicherheitsschuhe tragen bei der Arbeit
und ja, deswegen ist es gar nicht so gut mit dem Fuß da her.
Ja, ich verstehe. Und sind Sie verheiratet oder haben Sie...
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder.
Die sind auch noch alle zu Hause, ja.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die Kinder sind gesund, ja, ja.
Ganz gut.
Und, ach so, ich habe das vergessen.
Und gibt es in Ihren nähern Familien,
wie ich die oder die Grundchefin,
vor Erkrankungen, oder eher Erkrankungen?
Ja, also mein Vater hatte Magenkrebs, ja.
Der ist verstorben relativ früh,
aber sonst ist er eigentlich niemand krank.
Wie alt war er?
Oh, er war so Anfang 60.
Ja, das ist mir leid.
Und wissen Sie, warum Ihr Vater gestorben ist?
Er hatte Magenkrebs.
Magenkrebs.
Und, ja, Mutter?
Meine Mutter ist gesund, sie freut sich.
Sie ist ihres Lebensjahres.
Und haben Sie Geschwester?
Nein, ich war alleine zu Hause.
Ich bin leid.
Und gibt es in Ihrer Familie oder in Ihrem Arbeits,
in Ihrer Arbeits stressige Faktoren, die Sie belasten?
Natürlich überall gibt es Stress, also bei der Arbeit sowieso.
Und, ja, wenn man viel arbeitet, hat man Stress.
Und wenn man zu wenig hat, weil die Arbeitsplätze in Gefahr sind,
dann hat man auch Stress.
Ja, das lässt einem Augenblick natürlich nicht ruhen, ja.
Okay, ich weiß nicht, ich sage das.
Dann habe ich die alle nicht die Frage gestärkt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ich will jetzt vor allem natürlich, dass diese Schmerzen aufhören
und dass ich weiß, woher die kommen
und was man dagegen machen kann.
Dann tragen Sie gerade die Schmerzen nicht vor?
Ja, ich ertrage die schon, das sehen Sie ja.
Ich sehe hier vor Ihnen, aber die Schmerzen sind schon wirklich immer noch heftig.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Ich würde zuerst Ihnen körperlich untersuchen
und die Diagnose stellen.
Aber wenn Sie wirklich sehr starke Schmerzen haben,
würde ich zuerst Ihnen ein Schmerzmittel geben.
Das wäre vielleicht schon ganz gut, denn ich habe zwar jetzt Aspirin genommen,
aber das hat nicht so richtig was gebracht, ja.
Okay, ich werde Ihnen gleich ein Schmerzmittel geben.
Dann würde ich gerne körperliche Untersuchungen weitermachen.
Dann vielleicht einige Laborwerte müssen wir kontrollieren, überprüfen.
Danach können wir die Diagnose sprechen.
Das ist gut, ja.
Du warst vernünftig.
Ich war nämlich eigentlich ein bisschen anstrengend.
Was? Das war anstrengend?
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich die Anamese für mich esse.
Vor zwei Wochen haben wir eine Anamese-Duktifilm.
Seitdem bereite ich mich nicht für die Plüpfung,
sondern für welche ich nur in meinem Krankenhaus, in meinem Auspitalz-Pilaz.
Deswegen hatte ich ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten, die Frage jetzt erinnern.
Das war doch ganz gut.
Ich fand, Sie haben sich ganz gut geschlagen.
Wenn es irgendwas gab sprachlich, habe ich eigentlich gleich interveniert
und habe gleich gesagt, wie es richtig heißt.
Also, ja, kein Ding.
Möchte jemand noch etwas zusätzlich fragen von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen?
Ich weiß nicht, wo.
Hat jemand noch Fragen?
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
Genau, das stimmt.
Das hat er nicht gefragt. 7 bis 8.
Sie haben sich stark geschmessen, haben Sie noch etwas eingenommen und gegenschmessen?
Ja, ich habe Aspirin genommen.
Mama, da lässt der Aspirin ein.
Oh, das vor drei Stunden.
Oh, drei Stunden.
Brachten Sie jetzt eine Schmerzmittel?
Ja, hat er schon angeboten.
Hat er mir jetzt schon angemohrt?
Ich habe gesagt, ja, ich brauche etwas.
Das wäre gut.
Und er hat angekündigt, dass er mir gleich etwas geben will.
Und dann geht es mit der Untersuchung weiter.
Sie können aushalten.
Sagen Sie mir Bescheid, wenn Sie nicht mehr aushalten können?
Ja, er hat mir das schon angeboten.
Er hat ja gesagt, ich gebe Ihnen gleich ein Medikament
und dann untersuche ich Sie.
Hat er schon eigentlich gut gemacht?
Man könnte noch fragen, ob Sie eine erhebliche Fleischkonsum oder Alkoholkonsum gehabt hatten.
Erheblicher Fleischkonsum muss ich in diesem Fall bestätigen.
Wie sagt man?
Einige Leute behaupten, Fleisch wäre das beste Gemüse.
Also, gut.
Ich bin gerade mal in einer anderen Rolle geschluckt.
Als überzeugter Vegetarier musste ich jetzt hier gerade ein Fleischesser spielen.
Er liebt Fleisch und in jeder Form.
Mittags und abends und überhaupt zu jeder Tageszeit.
Und Alkohol hat er ja eigentlich auch selber gesagt.
Dass er außerdem Bier auch noch hin und wieder gerne mal einen Schnaps trinkt.
Okay.
Frau Schäpp-Pazen, haben Sie seit für neuer Patient?
Ja, haben Sie jemanden neu aufgenommen?
Ja.
Und Herr Frank Bezje, 46-jähriger Patient, heute,
stallte sich heute bei uns wegen,
heute Morgen plötzlich aufgetreten, stechern der Pulsieren der Schmerzen am rechten Fuß, vorne, vor.
Vorfuss?
Begleitet von Rubor, Kalor, Zumor und Funktion laser am Bettbruch im Bereich.
Und eine Verletzungen, Trauma oder eine Ausschütteradung von Schmerzen und Fieber wurden vermeint.
Und die Patienten erwähnte, dass sie Bewegungsbezüge...
Ja, der ist immer noch ein Mann.
Der Patient, der Patient erwähnte das, er bei der Bewegung Einschränkungen haben.
Und die vegetative Anamnese ist ganz unauffällig.
Und der Patient leidet an Hypercholestrenämie seit fünf, sechs Jahren.
Dagegen nimmt er keinen Medikament.
Und er leidet an arterielle Hypertonie seit fünf, sechs Jahren.
Und dagegen nimmt er eine unbekannte Medikament, der Patient erinnert nicht an Erdarm.
Und bei Bedarf nimmt der Patient aspirin 500 Pilgramm gegen Kopfschmerzen-Cefalgie und eine Magenschutzmedikamente wegen Sodrennen.
Ah, ja, okay.
Und er wurde als Kind, oder er hat sich appendectomiert.
Okay.
Unterzogen, würde ich sagen.
Unterzogen, wollen Sie sagen?
Ja, unterzogen.
Er hat sich unterzogen.
Ja, wobei dieser Begriff eigentlich so ein Stückchen diese Freiwilligkeit ausmacht.
Und gerade bei einem Kind würde ich sagen, passt das nicht so gut.
Und wenn ich jetzt mir heute ein neues Knie machen lasse, dann würde ich sagen, ich habe mich einer Knietapp unterzogen.
Aber er wurde als Kind appendectomiert, würde ich in so einem Fall sagen.
Okay.
Er wurde als Kind appendectomiert.
Und er ist nicht raucher und trinkt jeden Tag zwei, drei Bier.
Beim Ferien trinkt er mehr als normales.
Beim Feiern.
Ja, okay, bei Festgüten oder so, ne?
Und er hat keinen Kontakt, keinen Kontakt mit Folgen.
Und er ist Schluss, er ist Schluss von Beruf, verheiratet, hat drei gesunde Kinder.
Und in der Familienanamnese ist der Vater des Patienten im Alter 60 Jahren wegen Magenkalsnom gestorben.
Und seine Mutter ist gesund und er hat keine Geschwester.
Die alle Informationen vom Patienten sind.
Ja, was ist denn jetzt Ihre Verdachtstheatnose?
Wieder habe ich die Schwierigkeiten, die richtigen Diagnose zu stellen.
Ich habe gedacht, ich habe so eine breite Spur gelegt.
Vielleicht können Sie noch etwas sagen zum Allgemeinzustand des Patienten.
Okay, die Allgemeinzustand des Patienten ist mittel, wie kann ich sagen, mittel oder mittel ist.
Also normal würden Sie für Ärzte.
Normal.
Ja, okay.
Finden Sie?
Ich finde normal, was meinen Sie?
Der wiegt 114 Kilo bei 1,78 m.
Er ist übergewichtig.
Ja, also ordentlich, ne?
Ja, also Adipositas.
Und tatsächlich habe ich so erst gedacht, es ein Arthritis ist.
Arthritis, okay.
Ja, das ist ja immer schon mal eine Idee. Was könnte es noch sein?
Es kann romatologische Erkrankungen sein.
Eine, was?
Romatologische Erkrankungen.
Eine romatologische Erkrankung, ja, das kann es sein.
Und er ist viele fettige Essen.
Und Fleisch, habe ich richtig gehört, habe ich gehört.
Deswegen, es kann auch eine hyperurikeme sein.
Arthritis, eureka sein.
Ja.
Aber natürlich brauche ich die Patienten detailliert untersuchen.
Ich muss den Patienten detailliert untersuchen, ja.
Und die und Brut abnehmen und die Laborwerte kontrollieren.
Welche Laborwerte sind besonders interessant für uns?
Die Entzündungstarameter.
Einmal, ja, und was noch?
Und Urin im Blut?
Ja, wie sagt man zu Urin im Blut?
Haarstuf rein.
Ja, Haarstuf im Blut, ja, der Haarstuf rein.
Genau, der hat wahrscheinlich, ja, eine hyperurikeme.
Die richtige Diagnose war, oder ist hyperurikeme?
Nein, das wird sich im Labor zeigen.
Ja, ja.
Sie haben nicht so, wie machen Sie weiter mit Ihrer Untersuche?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung würde ich den Patient oder den Fuß einige Bewegungen durchführen.
Und welche Erleichterung es beeinträchtig ist, würde ich feststellen.
Bei der Inspektion würde ich Träck sehen, die Überwärmung.
Und bei der Palpation würde ich die Druckempfüglichkeit feststellen.
Wo erwarten Sie denn eine besonders ausgeprägte Druckempfindlichkeit?
Bei der hyperurikeme oder Arthritisurica.
Wenn es ein Anfall groß ist, würde ich zuerst Board kontrollieren.
Wie nennt man das denn?
Wenn die große Zähne Schmerz gibt es den Fachbegriff dafür?
Ja, es gibt es.
Pro Dagra.
Pro Dagra, ja.
Die Entzündung des großzählen Grundgelenks.
Die andere Gelenkung ist sehr populär.
Was wären denn noch denkbare Alternativen?
Sie haben zum Beispiel gefragt nach Blässe und nach Kribbelparästhesien.
Was wäre denn auch noch eine denkbare Alternative bei den Diagnomen?
Ja, Frau Kerl, würde ich sagen.
Was würden Sie deshalb noch untersuchen?
Ach so, tatsächlich sollte ich diese Frage stellen.
Wie viel Meter können Sie Schmerz freilaufen?
Im Augenblick kann er überhaupt nicht Schmerz freilaufen.
Was machen Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung, wenn Sie sichergehen wollen, dass es keine PRVK ist?
Drunkempfindlichkeit würde ich kontrollieren.
Die Arterienpuls würde ich kontrollieren.
Dann kann man praktisch ausschließen, dass er eine PRVK hat.
Wenn er eine kräftige Fußpulse hat, dann ist da nichts.
Ich würde auch mit anderen Fußpuls verbleiben.
Das ist wichtig.
Wie geht es weiter? Was können Sie untersuchen?
Was würde man wahrscheinlich sicherheitshalber auch noch machen?
Ich würde auch nach der Laborwerte untersuchen.
Nach der Laborwerte würde ich die apparativen oder bisgehende Massnahmen durchführen.
Zum Beispiel würde ich eine Interressionastomografie oder Röntgen beidseitig beidseitigen.
Warum die zweite Seite?
Es gibt keinen Traum, aber eventuell vielleicht...
Was könnte es auch noch sein, wenn er mit seinen 114 Kilo auf den Rippen hat, auf seinen Füßen rumläuft?
Der könnte ja noch eine spontanen Fraktur haben.
Das müsste man ausschließen mit dem Röntgenverfahren.
Schauen wir, ob das nicht eine Fraktur ist, die man bisher hat.
Er trägt Arbeitsschuhe, aber arbeitet in der Metallindustrie.
Er kann auch etwas schwierig sein, ohne dass er das bewusst ist.
Das ist sicher zu sein.
Tatsächlich hat er einen Gichtanfall der Patient.
Dafür sprechen vorallem die Risikofaktoren.
Sein übergewichtiger Ernährungszustand.
Und diese klassische Symptomatik.
Dass der eine Vorfuß massiv betroffen ist, heiß, gerötet, schmerzhaft, pulsierend.
Dass das plötzlich gekommen ist.
Das ist eine relativ typische Angelegenheit, dass ein Gichtanfall aus heiteren Himmel kommt.
Aber die Diagnose zu stimmen, brauchen wir nur die Laborwerte kontrollieren?
Eigentlich braucht man nur die Laborwerte.
Wenn die eindeutig sind, dann weiß man auch, was zu tun ist.
Was wäre die Therapie?
Bei der Arthritis-Bryka gibt es zwei verschiedene Therapie.
Beim Anfall und die chronische Therapie.
Beim Anfall würde ich Prätenisolon sagen.
Prätenisolon, also eine Koalition?
Ja, Koalition würde ich anfangen.
Und natürlich Schmerzmittel.
Und bei der chronischen Therapie, oder langsamer Therapie,
ich erinnere mich gerade nicht ganz gut, aber Purinol.
Hallo, Purinol, genau.
Ja, ich würde ihn anfangen.
Im Gichtanfall habe ich hier angegeben, Koalchizin, sagt Ihnen das was?
Ja, Koalchizin, vielleicht.
Wobei es hier im Fall angegeben ist.
Ich bin auch nicht sicher.
Was sagen wir dem Patienten für die Langzeittherapie noch?
Hallo, Purinol.
Ja, noch außer den Medikamenten.
Die Ernährung, die Eränderung, würde ich empfehlen.
Weniger Protein, ein natürlicher Sporttreiben.
Und Gewicht abnahm.
Gewicht zur Litung, genau.
Ganz genau.
Und Diät, genau.
Vielleicht sollte er auch weniger trinken.
Also Alkohol, zumindest Reduktion.
Gut.
Ich glaube, in der Türkei begegnet einem nicht so leicht ein
Giftpatient, aber in Deutschland ist es schon sehr wahrscheinlich,
dass sie in ihrem Leben mit einem Giftpatienten
konfrontiert werden, oder?
Vielleicht, sie haben rechts, weil in der Türkei nennen wir die
Patienten auf als reiche Menschenkrankheit.
Weil sie essen viel Fleisch.
Wohlstandskrankheit ist es wirklich, ja, genau.
Ja, und in Deutschland ist es inzwischen so,
dass wiederum die Leute, die sich bewusst ernähren,
das sind dann wiederum die reichen Leute heutzutage.
Und die Leute, die nicht so viel Geld haben,
haben eigentlich die schlechtere Ernährung heute.
Weil das Zeug alles so billig ist.
Hier ist Fleisch ja unendlich billig.
Fleisch zum Beispiel ist extrem billig.
Und ja, das wird dann eben auch entsprechend gekauft.
Und was hier eben auch sehr verbreitet ist,
sind diese Wurstwaren und so was, ja.
Diese weiterverarbeiteten Sachen,
wo dann auch alle möglichen Nitratsalze mit drin sind.
Also es ist eigentlich das pure Gift, ja.
Und die, also ich denke mal schon,
dass wir hier eigentlich einen übermäßig ungesunden
Lebensstil haben.
Und es war, also in der Nachkriegszeit war das so,
dass es natürlich als, nachdem die Leute
Jahrzehnte lang wirklich gehungert haben,
da war das wirklich das Zeichen von Wohlstand,
dass man Fleisch auf dem Teller hatte, ja.
Und da waren die Menschen ja in so einer Aufholstimmung,
ja, dass sie meinten Wohlstand und Fleisch essen ist ungefähr das Gleiche.
Ja, das war so diese Wirtschaftswunderzeit,
wo es mit einmal allen besser ging.
Und jetzt ist es natürlich schon auch so,
dass es bei uns auch bergab geht.
Aber wie gesagt, diese ganzen Fertigessen
und billig-Nahrungsmittel, die sind,
die gibt es einfach zu billig auf dem Markt.
Wir können uns zu üppig ernähren für wenig Geld.
Und das tun eben auch ganz viele und so ist es, ja.
Ja, aber ich, ja.
Zwei, sie können weiter sprechen.
Ich denke schon, dass sie als niedergelassener Arzt hier in Deutschland
beste Gelegenheit haben, Lichtpatienten kennenzulernen, ja.
Ja, aber ich wollte erst sagen,
dass System in Deutschland ein bisschen,
man muss diese Dinge essen oder sich ernähren,
weil viele Menschen arbeiten und sie haben nicht genug Zeit,
selbst kochen, selbst zu kochen.
Aber und viele Menschen verdienen auch nicht so viel Geld.
Ja, das ist genau der Punkt, ja.
Das ist die Grund, ja, ich denke.
Ja, ja.
Und das ist natürlich aufwendiger, wenn man selber kocht
und es braucht Zeit und man muss sich damit beschäftigen.
Aber die, ja, die Folgen sind unübersehbar.
Überall da, wo diese, diese, ja,
fertig Nahrung und vorfabrizierte Nahrung auf den Markt kommt,
gibt es den Menschen gesundheitlich einig schlechter.
Und selbst in den Ländern, die so berühmt sind für ihre gesunde Ernährung,
wie Japan zum Beispiel, auch da ist es so,
dass in der nächsten Generation jetzt diese American Way of Life
eben wo auch angekommen ist.
Und da haben wir, da haben wir eigentlich genau so eine Entwicklung,
dass die mit einmal irgendwelche Softdrinks zu sich nehmen,
wo sie früher grünen Teel getrunken haben, ja.
Also krasser geht der Wechsel eigentlich nicht.
Und ja, wir haben diese sogenannten Zivilisationskrankheiten.
Und ja, hier, unsere Gicht gehört bestimmt zu denen dazu.
Ja, gut.
Lassen Sie mich eben gucken.
Ich habe mir ganz wenig aufgeschrieben.
Es waren ein paar Sachen, die ich gleich korrigiert habe,
als Sie gesprochen haben.
Sie haben gemerkt, der Patient war so ein bisschen ungeduldig,
als Sie nach vielen, so allgemeinen Gesundheitsdienken gefragt haben.
Er hatte doch nur seine Fußprobleme, ja.
Das ist immer gut, wenn man sagt, ja, wir müssen ja den ganzen Menschen sehen, ja.
Und deswegen frage ich Sie auch danach,
wo ich manchmal denke, dass die Frage eigentlich ein bisschen zu harmlos ist,
wenn Sie sagen, haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen.
Kontakt haben heißt dann auch nicht so richtig konsumieren, ja.
Man könnte das durchaus, finde ich, ein bisschen präziser formulieren,
dass man sagt, haben Sie jemals Drogen probiert oder konsumiert?
Kann man eigentlich, und denn Kontakt ist ja, wie gesagt,
sehr oberflächlich.
Diese Frage hat mir mein Deutschlehrer gelernt.
Ja, ich weiß, dass das eigentlich alle sagen,
aber eigentlich gefällt mir das nicht so gut.
Ja, ich weiß.
Also, sobald man, denke ich, ein bisschen mehr verdacht hat,
sollte man schon sagen,
haben Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen gehabt
oder haben Sie jeweils konsumiert oder probiert oder konsumiert,
kann man ja, denke ich, schon mal nochmal nachfragen.
Ja.
Was mir nicht so gut gefallen hat, das war,
da bin ich mir jetzt auch wieder nicht mehr so sicher,
wie genau Ihre Formulierung war.
In der Familienanahmenese.
Da muss man eigentlich, ich glaube,
in der Familienanahmenese hatte der Vater
oder hat der Vater oder ist der Vater
an einem Magenkazenomen verstorben.
Eigentlich, die Familienanahmenese
ist ja die Befragung zu Krankheiten in der Familie.
Da kommt eine schöne Formulierung.
Ja, haben Sie jemals Drogen probiert oder konsumiert,
hat Dr. Pupel reingegeben.
Also, die Familienanahmenese ist ja eigentlich die Befragung
zum Gesundheitszustand der nächsten Angehörigen.
Das bedeutet, in der Familienanahmenese
gab der Patient an,
dass sein Vater an Magenkazenomen verstorben ist.
Dann sind wir, glaube ich, auf der sicheren Seite.
Und dann kann man hinterher sagen,
sozial an einem Nestisch ergab sich,
dass der Patient verheiratet ist, drei Kinder hat.
Und als Schlosser arbeitet.
Was mir nicht gefallen hat,
dass Sie nicht gleich von Anfang an gesagt haben,
dass der Patient so übergewichtig ist.
Weil das eigentlich in diesem speziellen Fall ja doch
für die
wahrscheinliche Diagnose
doch relevant ist.
Ja.
Ich meine, dieses im guten oder mittleren Allgemeinzustand,
das sagt man eigentlich nicht mehr so häufig.
Irgendein Kollege von Ihnen hat das mal konsequent gemacht,
dass er immer gesagt hat,
Patient in gutem Allgemeinzustand
zeitlich und örtlich und personell orientiert.
Das macht man so bei all den Leuten,
macht man das eigentlich oft.
Man sagt, Zeit, unerratlich orientiert.
Das würde ich jetzt also auch nicht generell
immer so...
Das ist ein schriftlicher Begriff.
Ja, eigentlich sowas, genau.
Aber ich glaube, man macht es auch gar nicht mehr so grundsätzlich,
dass man das zuschreibt.
Aber dieser Patient wäre ja auch tatsächlich
in einem schmerzbedingend reduziertem Allgemeinzustand,
aber eben in wirklich deutlich übergewichtigem Ernährungszustand.
Das müsste man eigentlich schon formulieren,
weil es eben maßgeblich ist für die weitere Geschichte.
Gut.
Wenn der Patient übergewichtig ist,
dann soll ich tatsächlich die Stömmatis
und die systematischen Erkrankungen überlegen.
Das bietet sich zumindest an, ja.
Ja, ich habe so verstanden.
Nein, umgekehrt.
Ich meine, wenn jemand mit einer Podagra kommt,
mit einem akuten Gichtanfall,
dann denke ich, ist das ein entscheidendes Kriterium,
dass dieser Patient auch heftig übergewichtig ist.
Ja.
Und ich meine, dass der natürlich hohen Blutdruck
und erhöhte Cholesterinwerte hat.
Das liegt so ein bisschen auf der Hand.
Ja, gut.
Ja, aber grundsätzlich würde ich immer sagen,
dass sie sprachlich sehr versiert sind,
dass sie eigentlich keine Probleme haben in der Kommunikation.
Es sind immer so ein paar Grammatikgeschichten drin,
wo sie ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten haben.
Aber das ist nie so etwas,
das jetzt die Verständlichkeit infrage stellt.
Mein Freundin sagt,
ob so die grammatische Fehler zeigen mir.
Aber ich habe bemerkt,
dass diese grammatischen Fehler oder falsche Dinge
ein bisschen wie nennen sie.
Denasorisch als Universität habe ich das Wort gehört.
Denasorische Fehler hat mein Deutschlehrer im Namen Sorge genannt.
Denasorische Fehler?
Denasorisch, oder?
Ich weiß, dass es falsch ist,
aber ich kann mich nicht ändern.
Es gibt ein Wort dafür.
Denasorisch, oder?
Tierrechts, oder Tierrechts?
Denasorisch?
Ja, aber es gibt auch neben dem Denasorisch ein Wort.
Es wird zusammen benutzt.
Ich erinnere mich gerade nicht daran.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich muss auch kein Mensch übersehen,
dass sie kein Muttersprachler sind.
Das kann man ruhig raushören.
Eigentlich empfinden wir es auch meistens ganz charmant,
wenn jemand mit einem kleinen Akzent spricht.
Das dürfen sie ruhig beibehalten.
Die ganz groben Schnitzer, würde ich sagen,
machen sie wirklich nicht.
Das ist alles auf sehr hohem Niveau,
wo ich jetzt reklamiert habe.
Das müsste in der Prüfung eigentlich gut gehen.
Gut.
Dann würde ich mal sagen, für heute haben wir es gut.